I think this isn't focus I want to go a
tech jake from vsauce3 but I don't know
where Carmichael is so I'm gonna go find
him
I came looking for you Vsauce is at
their office right now right they don't
have batteries for their remote so Jake
text means like hey can you bring us
some batteries we'll bring them
batteries over their dead bodies
you
hello I'm a GoPro welcome to the
neighborhood thank you oh good to see
let me hug you goodness this is the only
reason I moved makes you guys like it
take batteries penny only welcome to the
giant empty space that is the vsauce
office can you shoot anyone yet no this
is the first I've even even shown the
vsauce viewers yet he's not even
announced that you've moved into an
office at all no not yet
so thanks corridor digital for ruining
that for me there's a lot we got to do
AC this side of the office is gonna be a
studio I think it's the Time Warner
Cable man hello
yeah it's nasty
you must never know
now you're doing perfect don't change it
yeah so you gonna shoot all my stuff and
then move on to D stuff we're trying to
go back and back and forth cool yeah
we'll get me walking off from there
let's get a shot through the fence it's
like just a wide angle or you just see
me walking off and passing him and that
could be like the bystander angle ready
170 200 hi ready 3 2 1 action quickie
being in total shade like that makes it
so intense it's not pleasant
Obie help don't you
whoa in infrared so we can see right now
your ceiling is 110 degrees that is a
hot ceiling this is the coolest thing
that I didn't know about but now I do
okay here's here's an interesting fact
so right here behind this wall mm-hmm
you can see that there's a pillar here
and I'm that wall oh my god you can even
see the like the studs in the wall yeah
we're alone with adults or even though
that's a misconception thermal does not
give you expert but I can see studs yes
but that's like I can see em for Giroux
but I mean if we're being you know
really pedantic about it I feel like
that's kind of a little bit of x-ray I'm
seeing friends alone so I added a bunch
of nerf guns to my Amazon wishlist oh my
god I like office-supply wishlist a
whole bunch I mean there are tax
write-offs I think so yeah it's like we
need them but I love the reviews that
people have on Amazon about them like oh
this one fires at like this art like
rates permit as I do all this stuff then
you can mop them
yeah boom a red grant can you assassin's
creed yourself up is only gonna take
like five yeah in fact we challenged you
dollars worth the Taco Bell gift cards
and you can't make it up there that's
such a deal that isn't do you know
that's like a monthly reinforcement oh
god just keep going the challenge yeah
you can do it look at your little face
Oh the maple well I can't get up that
final 10% I'm disappointed but you guys
it was good seeing you guys
but I'll see you guys on Monday maybe we
can get tacos with taco truck together
so just come by anytime it's Freddy here
went to the ball caught it and then
threw it back at me that was low
so try to catch it my instincts with my
leg out and came short and hit me right
above the ankle sorry it's just a
baseball things don't mess up your game
ah nice alright so we're gonna see if
Clint's helmet could actually stop a
baseball hit ready oh god yeah our hands
II